[Music]
Hey hey focus stay back for Grindr
I love that you think I've enough
self-esteem to be on Grindr
I had the cerebral palsy the disability
in the brain manifested through muscular
and coordination okay now you're just
being a drama queen
Orion intern listen Cheyenne I need
viral content now I don't know what I
write about oh I was hit by a car
everybody Ryan he was hit by a car I
know he's a weird sound look forever
thank you so much okay that's great
that's enough thank you if you could get
rid of that thing you hate most about
yourself the thing no one else
understands what are you doing just
assumed my limp was from an accident and
then I never corrected him your
disability is part of you my mom that's
a secret boyfriend didn't you want her
to get a life you told me she was like
brie Larson and groom but like by choice
I'm moving out I'd like to see how you
function without an on-call maid
[Music]
getting hit by a car basically can just
mess my body up doesn't look so messed
up to me
[Music]
sometimes I just feel like as a non
skinny non-white girl I gotta work
overtime
I wasn't cause that about being gay and
then I'm in the closet by being disabled
and now no more closets
[Music]
merci liar you got anything - getting
straight white men are canceled
[Music]
you